[Music]  a henderson doggie daycare has its  license revoked from the city today  dakota's doggy den runs out of a home  near  u.s 95 in college well today animal  control officers showed up to find 51  dogs inside that home the city issued a  citation against the owner for having  too many dogs  we spoke to the owner who says she's  been working closely with the city to  make sure that she  is following the rules it's the same  officer that gave me that information  yesterday and told me  i had this and they weren't explaining  to me why  what changed they didn't say anything as  to why anything changed  why they were telling me something why  they were pulling my license today  half of those dogs were returned to  their owners the rest taken to the  henderson shelter where they can be  picked up free of charge  we're going to continue to follow this  story to learn more about exactly what  happened between the business and the  city